thanks guys we're here with a winner of
round seven maxim bashir lagrave seems
like you were having a little bit of
trouble there with shaq but counter play
was found yeah certainly i didn't do
well in the opening and yeah my position
was uh beyond suspicious so here
shark just grabs a pawn i thought maybe
queen c5
made sense it looks like it does just
then maybe to follow a probability it
was
yeah not i don't know but anyway he took
then i went rook c8 and rd8
and somehow here i've found contour pro
which i shouldn't have found yeah i
guess e3
yeah e3 was called for then i probably
can just resign
and then suddenly
e3 comes
and i guess you should take but of
course it's sad to
to make a draw of here right you just
have f4
suddenly it's very tricky so like kg2
knight g6
and my queen's after b5 h5 let's say my
queen is contouring the pawn on a4 so
no majority can advance
i do threaten things on the king side i
mean dark squares are always open so the
bishop cannot move because of the queen
so because the bishop cannot move the
queen cannot move and like even let's
say you have queen on d5 bishop on b3
like okay let's play some random move
you go bishop is here i still go quinny
one you take and it's made yeah you're
just not saving yourself yeah alone made
you so that means it's very tricky to
play and here
yeah this i was not sure but i thought
it's very tricky because kg2 queen h4 is
almost made and apparently there's save
which
is beyond difficult to find yeah and
backward maneuver and then no i mean i
saw this idea but not with the king on
h3 which has no move but
anyway it seems like
so after king f1
i mean i start for a while about 95
knight c4 but there's queen d5 queen g5
check
and i was like am i gonna really make a
draw here and then i found this very
nice maneuver with knight f8 absolutely
beautiful and i thought his only chance
was queen g5 and g5 but here i was
confident i'm never in danger right
again like the king is caught
the queen is
remains to protection exact scenarios
where i even play knight takes g5 which
is huge blender and maybe it's not as
lost as it looks yeah like
okay it is but
um
but then he played a5 and
yeah i saw this
and apparently
whoa
okay but this is tough yeah it's very
tough especially with the time that he
healed remaining and the trajectory i
just assumed i missed grenade
this is really tough that's very hard
yeah yeah study uh so that means here i
should have gone 96 of course
which i did just move later and after
queen c2 so the point is if i go queen
d80 immediately which is what i would
want there's g5
and well it's still winning but this was
that was the idea to bring the queen
back right so but after 96 queen c2 no
queen d8 and
queens you've had a couple of close
calls here so far in the rapid but the
points keep piling up how do you feel
about your performance so far uh it's
all right of course i
i had one
big miss against a user but at the same
time i was much worse right for the
whole game basically so you know i feel
like i'm defending very toughly
um still need maybe to put the nail you
know
in the right place in some of the games
but plus two is very distant square and
this thing is uh jordan is piling up the
point right yeah tell me about jordan
you think that he's in shape
well he's definitely in shape
in
even better shape than i predicted and i
predicted him that he was gonna do well
so so far i've been he's lucky charm i
guess absolutely well hopefully you're
your own lucky charm and the rest of the
tournament plus two a very good score so
far maxime hopefully you accumulate more
points throughout the rest of the day
guys maxima sherlock graph with a big
win here in round seven over chakra
medyarov thank you